jack sim has taken his landlord to court
sued him and won
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds in
this video i'm going to be addressing a
very controversial court case that has
just happened involving landlords and
students so if you are interested in
becoming a landlord or if you're just
generally interested in the property law
and what's going on in the news i'm
going to talk about this story i'm going
to explain exactly what happened and i'm
going to tell you why it's really
important you take note of this case
because it's the first of potentially
many court cases like it now this case
has been picked up by bbc news and of
course the media
hate landlords the media don't like the
property investors generally speaking so
of course everybody's saying that's
brilliant news the landlord's been sued
isn't it excellent but i really just
wanted to share exactly what happened um
and also from a landlord perspective
what we can learn from this and give my
two pennies so if you enjoy my channel
please don't forget to smash the like
button also subscribe i'm going to be
giving lots more updates around
important news articles in property and
if you want to get the
the version that's going to help you as
a property investor as opposed to just
sell stories and get clicks then
subscribe to this channel so what
happened is this guy called jack sim now
jack sim is a 19 year old law student
has just sued his landlord and the
reason he sued his landlord is because
the property didn't look like and didn't
appear like the property that he
actually signed up for now when i first
read this and when i you know i heard
the response of all the other landlords
people generally speaking were quite
annoyed with
jack sem from the landlord property
community because effectively you've got
this young kid he's 19 years old he's
studying law
he moves into a property he doesn't like
the property he says that it wasn't like
the pictures were advertised he said
that it was busy there was workmen all
around everywhere it was like a building
site he moved out and then he took the
landlord to court and he sued the
landlord and the landlord put in a
counter claim and said that he moved out
after a month and he should have been
there six months so it goes to court
bank jack sim
wins
the landlord has to pay back the deposit
has to pay back the rent that he paid
and the landlord's counter claim was
thrown out by the courts now
generally speaking i think the narrative
from a landlord perception is
dude if you don't like the place so much
just move out however
i am actually after thinking it through
and after reading about the case i am
in favor of what jack sam the student
did and i actually agree with him and
let me explain why
the way that property is working these
days more and more tenants are doing
viewings virtually because with the way
technology is now video tours computer
generated imagery photographs
why would you especially if you're
moving into a property where you're
moving for a long distance reason you're
relocating to the area you might be
coming from a different country why
would you come all the way and spend all
that time on transport to look at a
property when you can just look at it
virtually it's becoming more and more
popular and convenient to reserve a
property without actually looking at the
property because you just rely on the
landlord or the marketer or the agent
providing you with the video information
with that being said it's very easy to
mislead tenants and say oh it looks like
this and shows something that's actually
not quite right and by the looks of it
when you actually read about what the
property was like you know it's been
described as a building site so it
sounds like a noisy terrible property so
to be honest i can understand why jack
sim
wanted to move out and not only is the
landlord wasted jack's time but also
cost him money inconvenience so i
actually think i can understand why jack
said look i want my money back you know
jack's not trying to sue him um for a
huge amount of money he just wants his
money back he wants his deposit back and
i think that the landlord should have
given it back i think that the landlord
should have apologized and said i'm
really sorry the house has not been
anything like advertised and because the
landlord didn't do that
jack sim
knows the law because he's a law student
and he still understands basic
contractual law and says actually you
know what you miss sold me and the
property's not like it was advertised
and i want my money back and legally i i
i can ask for that so i actually think
that jack deserved to win the case and i
think he should be a shake up to
landlords if you're a property owner you
don't have anything to worry about as
long as you just don't mislead your
tenants just make sure that what you
advertise is what you deliver i really
believe in business that you should
under promise and over deliver and i
think that's the same in properties as
well you know you want to add extra
surprises make sure your properties are
amazing and then you're going to have
good tenants you're gonna have
long-standing tenants and you're not
gonna have court cases so it's very
interesting case i think there's lessons
all around i'd love to know what your
opinion is though do you think that the
landlord was hard done to do you agree
with me do you think that actually jack
was right let me know your comments
below i'm going to be talking about some
of the latest news updates as well um
coming up in the property news and
giving my thoughts on it and it's really
important as well because a lot of the
the news stories they're just trying to
sell stories they bash landlords but
here you'll get a position the
perspective from the land that's
actually going to help you in property
and keep you informed so let me know
your thoughts comment below and uh don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe see you next time
[Music]
you